- I'm surprised at the
left's message to men,
which is that manhood
is inherently toxic,
they love this phrase
"Toxic masculinity."
But if you listen closely,
and I quote this
stuff in the book,
if you listen closely to
what the leftists believe,
they think all manhood is toxic.
There's one social
scientist who said,
"Talking about
healthy masculinity
"is like talking
about healthy cancer."
(ambient music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today is a
US Senator from Missouri,
an author of the brand new book
"Manhood: The Masculine
Virtues a Man Needs."
Senator Josh Hawley, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you for having me.
- Senator, I wish we were
recording about 30 seconds ago
because you very
sarcastically said to me
you're in DC doing
important work.
And I wasn't sure if
it was sarcasm or not.
- Oh yeah, it was total sarcasm.
I think my next comment
was ruining the country
one day at a time,
which anytime they say
that the senate's not
gonna be in session,
I usually say it's
probably good, right?
I mean, not doing any damage,
but in all seriousness,
the last two years,
I mean, (chuckling)
it has been something to
watch this administration
and their allies in Congress
do what they've been doing,
it's unbelievable.
- Yeah, so my audience, as
you know, will fully get that,
whether it's borders,
which I wanna talk to
you about in a second,
or economy, foreign policy,
I mean, just the
whole freaking thing.
So when you're there
now in DC, in session,
obviously the Republicans
have the House back,
so that's something, not
the Senate, but the House.
Are you feeling any momentum
to turn any of this around?
Or is it just sort of why you
made this sarcastic remark
in the first place?
- Well, no, I think
there is momentum.
I mean, certainly
having the House back
in Republican hands is great,
I mean, that's outstanding.
We're already seeing
a difference on that.
We should have had the Senate,
I mean, there's just
really no excuse
for Republicans not to
have won back the Senate,
other than what Senate
Republicans offered voters,
which was nothing.
So if you don't offer anything,
how can you expect
people to vote for you?
I mean, that's my takeaway.
But certainly, I think
that we are able now
to stop much of
the Biden agenda.
We're able to go
on the offensive,
this border crisis
is a good example.
I mean, Republicans
actually have a border plan,
which is pretty easy, it's
called "Enforce the law."
I mean, we've got pretty
good laws on the books,
this isn't hard, enforce them,
the border should be closed.
If you want to come
to this country,
you should do it legally.
If you want to apply for asylum,
fine, you gotta do that
through the legal process.
And then you should
wait in Mexico
or another safe country,
safe third country,
while your claims are
processed, et cetera.
So I think that we can
certainly make some progress.
But listen, I mean, people
can see the reality.
I mean, this president
is a radical leftist,
or he's given in to the
radical left agenda,
and they have been
running rough shot
for the last two years, and
we've gotta turn that around.
- Let's just dive into the
border thing for a moment,
because these videos
coming from our southern
border are insane.
I mean, it looks like
a zombie invasion.
I'm sorry, every zombie
movie you ever see,
people flying over the walls,
that's basically
what it looks like,
and nobody's really
doing anything.
I mean, what can
you as a senator do
when you talk to, say,
Cruz down in Texas,
what can you do to
help them down there?
Because obviously,
the federal government
is not gonna do anything.
- Well, one of things we had
to do is give states the power
to actually enforce
federal immigration law.
And you saw Governor
Abbott down in Texas
send a Texas National
Guard troops to the border.
I've introduced legislation
that would say, "Listen, I mean,
"the federal government's not
gonna enforce our own laws,
"let's give the states the
power to enforce federal laws."
I'm not talking
about make the laws,
I'm talking about enforce the
laws that are on the books.
Again, this shouldn't
be that hard.
So that's something
we should do.
That's something
that we could do.
But in terms of what's
gonna have to happen,
we're going to have to
get an administration
that actually believes
in the rule of law.
Solving the border crisis, I
think, is not that hard, Dave,
all you have to do is Title
42 ought to be permanent.
We gotta leave it in
place permanently.
By the way, there's
bipartisan support for that
on Capitol Hill.
And then we ought to have
safe third agreements
with other countries,
which just means
that if immigrants wanna
come to this country
and they're claiming asylum,
fine, they can apply for asylum,
but they've gotta do it
first in another country.
And if they apply
for asylum in the US,
they've gotta wait
in another country
while their claims
are processed,
you can't just come in here
and go into the interior of
the country and disappear
while claiming asylum.
Well, we've gotta
put a stop to that.
- Are you shocked that, as
2024 rolls around, that Biden,
whether it is him or it's
the radicals, as you said,
beneath him in the party,
that this is the
direction they're going?
As crazy as the Democrat
party has become,
I don't see how this could
possibly be thought of
as a winning thing
until you flood us
with enough people that will
just vote for Democrats.
But in the meantime, I think
it turns off a lot of people,
just optics wise.
- Yeah, I think it's crazy.
I think what it
really shows though
is their religious
devotion to their ideology.
I mean, they are devoted to
this globalism of open borders.
I mean, let's gotta remember
who the base is now,
the Democrat Party,
the base of the Democrat party
flies around in private jets
and goes to
conferences at Davos,
that's their base now,
that's who they are.
They love this
open border stuff.
They want to collapse
the immigration system.
They want cheap labor.
If you ask me what I think is
really driving a lot of this,
they want cheap labor.
And that's why they like illegal
immigration in particular,
because illegal immigrants,
but you can pay them nothing,
that's what they want.
These global corporations who
are the base of the dem party,
they want the cheap labor.
So bring them over, let the
cartels have free reign.
And if kids in Missouri
die from drug overdoses
because all the drugs
flooding across the border,
"Nah, that's just
collateral damage,"
the way these people think,
which is totally unconscionable
and morally wrong.
And Joe Biden has
that on his shoulders.
I mean, these are his
policies, he's responsible.
- It's just incredible
watching these videos.
But let's just hit a
couple other things.
You've also been
pretty outspoken on
the Ukraine situation.
It seems to me the machine
is just endlessly
marching us to war,
that it's either about money,
funding things,
giving them weapons,
there's just no off ramp here.
Do you see any way we
can reverse some of this
without World War III?
- Well, what needs to happen
is we need to say that,
first of all, we need to give
no more money to Ukraine,
I mean, period.
I voted against this, I'm
against this continual funding.
It's clear to me,
you basically are just
talking about escalation.
And it looks to me like
the Biden administration
has a policy of
unending escalation,
just more and more and more.
Now we know that they're
actually US troops
of some variety in Ukraine.
We were told they weren't
because of all these
intelligence leaks,
now we know there are,
so who knows what else
they're lying to us about.
But it's constant
escalation, more money.
Apparently, the ruling
class has learned nothing
from Afghanistan
and Iraq, nothing,
right down to
lying to the public
and lying to Congress
at every turn
about what we're actually doing.
So step number one-
- Well, maybe they learned that
they could get away with it.
Is that what they learned,
that they can do that,
and it keeps going?
- Maybe, I mean, maybe,
I guess you could argue
they kind of got away
with it in Afghanistan,
except for you provoke
the voters of this country
finally to say, "No
more of this stuff."
Joe Biden felt that he had
to get out of Afghanistan
because the voters had had
enough of this endless war.
I think we're there
with Ukraine as well.
But yeah, I mean, they
just keep going and going.
So my view is no more money.
Number two, we need
accounting of every dollar
that's been spent, I mean,
this should not be difficult.
We ought to know every
dime, where has it gone,
what has it been used for?
We've sent Ukraine over a
hundred billion dollars.
Even if you loved what
was happening with Ukraine
and you thought
the United States
should be fighting
on the ground,
surely you'd want to know
how our money is being spent.
But yet I can't get senators
to vote for basic accounting,
but we'll just keep after it
until we can actually
get the truth here
about how our dollars
are being spent.
- Let me hit you on one other,
which is just the
economy in general.
We had Silicon Bank going down,
Silicon Valley Bank
about a month ago,
then about two weeks ago,
my bank, First Republic,
is now part of Chase.
Too big to fail,
keeps getting bigger.
What do we do about this?
- Well, first of all, I'm
totally against the bailouts.
I mean, let me just tell you,
I don't agree with people
in Missouri or anywhere else
having to pay for these
billionaires in California
to get bailed out.
I can tell you what would happen
if a bank failed in
the state of Missouri,
Community Bank failed in
what they would say is,
what all these New York Wall
Street people would say is,
"Oh, that's the free market,
we just have to live with it."
But when it's full of liberals
who are doing stuff
like their green agenda,
which is what
Silicon Valley Bank
was heavily invested
in apparently,
oh, then it's different,
then it's systemic risk,
whatever that means.
Then the taxpayer is
gonna be on the hook.
I am totally opposed to that
as to why this is happening.
The big banks are
out there right now.
If you ask me and just talking
to people watching this,
the big banks are out there
trying to drive down the stock
and trying to drive
down the assets
of these medium size
and smaller banks
'cause they wanna
gobble 'em all up.
And the Biden
administration's helping them,
they're for that, because
the bigger the banks get,
then the more the government
can partner with the big banks.
And they want
three or four banks
that will be basically
controlled by the government
because then they can debank
and decredit people who don't
do what they're told to do,
like gun owners and people who
sell guns, for one example.
- Right, so we get
three or four banks,
but in essence, we
really just get one bank
because it's the United
States government saying.
So what do we do about that?
I mean, we keep hearing more
about this like global currency
or there's gonna be this
United States digital currency.
DeSantis is fighting hard
against it in Florida,
it sounds like about
20 other red states
are kind of joining him on that.
Is it just inevitable
that we'll all continue
to go in this direction?
- Oh no, goodness sakes, no.
No, it's not inevitable.
We've gotta hit reverse.
I mean, one of the
things I disagree
with a lot of my fellow
Republicans in Washington about
is that they've been
for this big bank stuff.
I mean, they're the ones
who have put in place,
or in some instances,
taken away the barriers
for letting the big
banks get bigger.
So what should we do?
I think we ought to
say to the big banks,
"You can't get
any bigger, sorry,
"you can't buy up anymore
"of these small and medium
sized banks, no more."
Number two, we're
not gonna bail,
we're not gonna
sweeten this deal
by bailing out all
of these banks,
because who profits from that?
What happens is the
big banks come in,
they get the bailout
money essentially,
and they gobble up
the little banks.
So we're gonna stop that
whole sweetheart deal,
no more of these
secret bailouts.
We're not gonna let the
big banks get any bigger.
And we're gonna play
put in place laws
that actually help and protect
community banks like local,
truly local banks,
where people know each other
and you can go get a loan
from somebody who knows you,
and it's not being
controlled and dictated
by Washington or Wall Street.
- Makes sense to
me, we shall see.
All right, let's talk
about the book a little bit
'cause I was flipping
through it this morning,
and you're channeling your
inner Jordan Peterson,
if I'm not mistaken.
- Well, I think
that Jordan Peterson
has been a powerful
and much needed voice
in encouraging men all
around the world in his case,
but men in this country
need to hear it,
to say to them,
"Listen, we need you,
"you are needed,
you are important.
"You can be a force for good
and we need you to step up.
"So turn off the computer
in mom and dad's basement,
"come on out, go get a job,
"maybe get married,
start a family."
That is how you're
gonna leave a legacy.
That is how you can
change this country.
And really the
book is about that.
It's about how we need men
to be all that they can be
so that America can
be all that we can.
- Are you surprised that you
had to write a book like this?
I've heard you talk
about this before,
the issue about men in society,
but look, you're a senator.
Mostly people would think,
"Oh, he's gonna write
a book about politics,"
but that's really
not what this is.
- No, yeah, it's
not about politics.
And I suppose it is surprising
given just where we are.
I'm surprised at the
message to the left,
left's message to men,
which is that manhood
is inherently toxic,
they love this phrase,
"Toxic masculinity."
But if you listen closely,
and I quote this
stuff in the book,
if you listen closely to
what the leftists believe,
they think all manhood is toxic.
There's one social
scientist who said,
"Talking about
healthy masculinity
"is like talking
about healthy cancer."
There you go, that's
the less view.
And they tell our kids this,
I've got two little
boys who are school age,
I worry about what are
they hearing in school,
what are they hearing
from the media.
This is really the big
reason I wrote the book,
I was thinking
about my own boys.
Our boys, from the
time they're small,
are told that being
a man is a problem,
that men, when
they are masculine,
hurt things, break things,
make society worse.
We need to send the
exact opposite message,
that we need strong men,
we need you to
stand up and provide
and protect and sacrifice,
and you can change your family,
you can change
your neighborhood,
you can change your
country, if you'll do that.
- We play the videos on my
show every now and again.
But if you wanna see how
toxic masculinity is,
go watch the videos from 1920's
New York City, Manhattan,
when they have these guys
up on those skyscrapers,
not strapped into anything,
hanging off there,
building the Empire State
Building, absolutely incredible.
What was really
the genesis of it?
Was it really looking
at your kids and going,
"They need a message on this."
Where do you think we
really went off the rails
on this thing?
- Well, I think, in terms
of why I wrote the book,
yeah, I've got a 10-year-old
and an 8-year-old, both boys.
And then I've got a baby
girl, who's my youngest.
But as my boys now get
older, really for me,
the book started with
me thinking about
what's my obligation as a dad
to help my boys be who
they were meant to be.
I mean, what is it
that I'm teaching 'em?
And I look at what the
culture is teaching them.
I'm like, "Man, that is
frightening and it is wrong."
And so the book really started
about me thinking through
that with my own kids.
And the book is really about
holding out role models.
I talk a lot about
American history,
I talk a lot about the Bible,
role models of what to look like
to be a strong man
and to be a good man
and tell those stories
about being a husband,
being a father, being a warrior,
being a builder, being a
priest, and being a king.
And each of those is
a chapter of the book.
And it's really saying to men,
"Hey, there's something
that for you to go after,"
we need you to step up and be
a contributor in these ways.
So that's how it started.
How do we go wrong?
I think it's really the left
and their embrace
of this new Marxism,
which says that manhood is
toxic, that manhood is evil,
that American society
is systemically racist
and oppressive and bigoted,
and men are the problem.
And that's a message
men are told,
especially boys are told from
the time they are little.
And we've gotta counteract that
'cause it is just dead wrong.
- How much of that stuff
is leaking into your life,
your constituent's
life in Missouri?
I feel like people
think about this stuff,
they're like, "All right, it's
happening in schools in Cali,
"it's happening in New York,
"but it's probably not
happening in Missouri."
- Oh no, it's in the
curriculum everywhere.
I mean, that's the
sad part about it
is that it is in
school curriculum.
Look at the data, don't
take my word for it,
just look at the data,
look how often boys, young boys,
elementary age boys are
diagnosed with ADHD,
versus girls, versus
other demographics, right?
I mean, it is overwhelmingly,
boys have been medicated
basically into submission
in our schools.
We've had a constant mantra
that boys shouldn't be
allowed to play aggressively,
if they bring toy
soldiers to schools.
There's something
wrong with them
if they bring a toy gun to
school, that's an intervention.
It's crazy, it starts
early, and it's everywhere.
I have parents talk to me
from all over my state,
all over the country,
come and say that,
"I just heard this happen,
"my kid brought a
G.I. Joe to school,
"he was disciplined for
it," et cetera, et cetera.
It is crazy, crazy stuff.
What is the effect
of that society-wide,
again, just look at the numbers.
Record numbers of young men
suffering from depression,
record numbers of young men
trying to commit suicide,
struggling with drug
abuse and alcohol abuse,
and record numbers
of men not working.
So if you like that
pattern, then I'd say,
"Great, keep doing what
the left wants you to do."
But for those of us who say,
"No, actually we
need men to work,
"we need men to be
fathers and husbands,
"we need men to step
up and provide,"
we gotta do something different.
- How much of this
at the end of the day
do you put on the parents?
I mean, I think everyone gets
that the culture's
working against us
and okay, the movies, the TV
shows, Disney, blah blah blah,
but at the end of the day,
and I say this with
certain amount of irony,
I mean, I have basically an
8-month-old and a 6-month-old,
so I'm not there yet.
But that it really
is you, the parent,
that should set the agenda here.
And I think too many parents
probably just
didn't realize that
or got lost on their phones
or whatever it might be.
- Well, I think that it's hard
to parent in this environment
when it's basically
you versus the world.
I mean, when it's you
versus what your kids
are being told in school,
and what we learned in COVID is,
and a lot of times parents,
they don't know what's
going on in school
not 'cause they
don't wanna know,
but because as we
found it in COVID,
administrators keep it from 'em.
"I wanna see my
kids' curriculum."
"Oh, no, you're not allowed."
"No, I wanna come and
sit in on a class."
"Oh, no, no, you're
not allowed."
"Oh, I wanna see what
they're reading."
"No, you're a
domestic terrorist,
"we're gonna kick you outta
the school board meeting."
That's what we discovered
in the last couple years.
So parents, whether it's
schools, whether it's big tech,
I mean the kids
get on the phone,
and it's like the parents
tried it, monitor it,
but meanwhile these kids have
constantly pushed to them
this imagery, this
rhetoric, this ideology
about how they're not
the gender that they are
is not what they should be,
that there's no such thing as
gender, we could go on and on.
So I think, listen, as a
parent myself of three,
I have a lot of sympathy
for parents who are like,
"Wow, I feel totally
overwhelmed."
And that's one of the
reasons I wrote this book
is I think particularly
every father out there
is trying to figure out,
I'm sure it's true of
you, trying to figure out,
"Okay, how can I raise my kids
"in a way where they can be
all that they're meant to be?"
And part of that is
we band together,
we tell the stories that we
know and that inspire us,
that call us up to be something
more and something better.
- How would you scale that up?
Do you think that really just
starts obviously in the home
and then hopefully at the
school and then school board
and kind of up that way?
Or is there a way to kind
of put that on steroids?
'Cause obviously, we're working
against algorithms here,
that's a tough battle.
- Yeah, it is great point.
We are working
against algorithms.
I do think it
starts in the home,
but I do think that we've gotta
strengthen those networks,
the churches, synagogue,
I mean, these places that
are places of real community,
not the virtual online
kind, which is fake largely,
but the real communities,
where parents band together
and they raise
their kids together
around their common values.
We need more of that
in this country.
And at the national
level, policy level,
we need policies that
actually encourage that.
We gotta be encouraging
marriage rather than,
we still penalize
marriage in our tax code.
I mean, it's unbelievable.
We're still sending jobs
overseas, stupidest thing ever,
4 million jobs, blue-collar
jobs lost to China
since the year 2000.
One of the biggest,
stupidest policy mistakes
in American history,
we're still doing it.
We need to turn that around,
bring back jobs
where men can work,
provide for their families,
contribute to their
neighborhoods.
So there are things that need
to be done at a policy level,
but really we gotta put power
in the hands of parents,
fathers, and mothers,
and we've gotta strengthen them.
- You mentioned common values.
I'm just back from
10 days in Israel
and four days in Hungary,
and one of the
things that I found
was these are two countries
that despite all their
political disagreements
internally and everything
else, they have common values.
It's very obvious
what it is with Israel
in terms of religion
and Hungary as a small country
trying to protect their borders,
their Christian heritage,
et cetera, et cetera.
What do you think the common
values are for Americans?
'Cause I think
that's what we seem
to be struggling with most.
It's like we're
350 million people,
we all look different, came
from all these different places,
what is the common part?
- Well, I think what's in common
is the history and the
principles that unite us.
And in that you can go to our
Declaration of Independence,
and you can look at our belief,
that we have inalienable
rights that are endowed to us
given to us by our
creator, not by government,
and you look at
what underpins that.
I mean really, the
tradition of the Bible.
I know I'm not
supposed to say this,
the left hates it when I say
this stuff, but it's just true.
The tradition of the Bible
has underwritten a lot
of American culture
and a lot of our
shared principles.
And that's been true,
whether you are a
religious believer or not,
it wasn't that long
ago in this country,
you'd say, yeah, the
principles of the Bible,
maybe for some
people, it's like,
"I don't think that
they're literally true,
"but I agree with them
in principle," et cetera.
That has been
our fundamental shared
tradition in this country.
It gave us things like
liberty of conscience,
liberty of speech,
liberty of assembly,
these fundamental rights.
And what the left
has been doing is,
the left has been running down
our whole history and saying,
"No, American history,
systemically racist,
"American values,
systemically bigoted,"
they wanna overthrow all of it.
This is the Marxist
element in them.
They wanna overthrow all
of our cultural heritage.
And I think we as conservatives,
we've gotta be about preserving
those things that unite us,
our basic fundamental commitment
to our inalienable rights,
to liberty of conscience,
liberty of assembly,
liberty of worship.
We've gotta go back to
those fundamental things
that hold us together,
and that includes our
biblical tradition.
- What do you do about the
people on the other side
that just obviously
don't believe that,
when basically AOC tells Biden
that he should ignore
judicial rulings,
or it's fairly obvious
that half of the party,
I don't even think
I'm being sarcastic,
and probably more
than half the party,
they simply don't believe
that the founding
of America is good.
It's one thing to have a
difference of political opinion,
but the fundamental tenants
seem wildly opposite
or oppositional.
I don't know how
you get over that.
- Yeah, exactly, and
just to that point,
I mean, that's the part
of the Democrat party,
the Marxist part,
that says that this country
was really founded in 1619.
I mean, we were
founded on oppression,
we were founded on
slavery, those are lies.
And I think what
do we do about it?
We have to call 'em out as lies.
I mean, you just can't
compromise with that.
I mean, we can
respect the people.
I mean, I serve with a lot
of these people in Congress,
respect them, it's people,
happy to have a
discussion about it,
but I'm not going to say that,
"Oh yeah, you have
a good point there."
"No, you don't actually."
The country was not founded
in 1619, sorry, that's a lie.
We were not founded
on oppression.
America's a nation
of liberators,
not a nation of oppressors.
That's the truth, we
have to say the truth.
This country has a deep
heritage in the Bible,
that's the truth, you
can like it or hate it,
but that's the truth, we
should speak the truth.
So I think we've got
to tell the truth.
This is a time for truth
telling in this country.
And I think that's the solution,
and we just cannot go
along with the lies.
And you can do
that respectfully,
and you can do that
civilly, and we should,
but you gotta tell the truth.
- You've been leading
on the text stuff
sort of outside of this,
but this is obviously
very connected to
the tech side of it.
I mean, I'll watch my
niece flip through TikTok,
and you just suddenly
outta nowhere, literally,
"It's my little pony,"
and then it's some
weird gender thing,
and then five more videos
and something else.
What do we do about that?
I know you've been one of the
guys trying to figure out,
"Okay, do we break 'em up?"
When are we supposed to
use government power here?
- Well, I just say
again as a dad,
I wanna raise my
kids, my wife and I,
we wanna raise our kids.
I don't want big tech
raising 'em for me.
I don't want some algorithm
raising 'em for me, period.
So I'm against tech
being able to track our
kids all over the internet,
collect all their
personal information,
build dossiers on them,
I think we should just prohibit
that, just straight up,
like you cannot target
children under a certain age.
You cannot build
dossiers on them.
And I think we ought to
give every parent in America
the right to get their
kids information back
from all these social
media platforms.
You ought to be able as a
father to go on and say,
"Okay, my 10-year-old kid."
Now my kids are not
on social media,
but I know the day is coming,
I'm trying to delay it,
but as a parent, I want
the right to go on and say,
"I want from Facebook everything
you've collected on my kid,
"I want it all back.
"You delete it, give
it to me, delete it."
Every parent ought to
have that basic right.
You mentioned breaking 'em up,
I am a big competition guy,
so my view is is that Facebook,
Google, they're monopolies.
I mean, they really are.
They've tried to kill
competition all the time.
We ought to break them up and
let there be more competition.
We ought to allow others
to get in there to compete
and to have real
privacy protections.
But bottom line is we gotta
give power to parents,
gotta give them power
to protect their kids,
to get their kid's information.
Don't allow big
tech to raise kids.
- Yeah, did you focus at all
on the female side of this?
I know that, obviously, the
book is about young males,
there's a whole
other set of issues
happening with young females,
many of them seem to be
transitioning more than males,
although it's happening
both directions.
I assume you think some of the
issues are somewhat constant.
- Oh, absolutely, and
particularly with tech.
I mean, listen, I think
the left has a war
on the whole idea of gender.
It's a war on men, but
it's also a war on women.
It looked no further
than their campaign
to get biological men
into women's sports.
I mean, this is insane.
We couldn't even have
imagined this conversation
three or four years ago.
But the idea is now like an
article of faith with them
that a biological man must be
able to play in women's sports
and use the locker room
with the girls is insane.
So yeah, I think what
you're seeing from the left,
again, from the
Marxist left really,
is a campaign against gender,
it's against womanhood,
it's against manhood.
There are a lot of similarities
there in how they're trying
to destroy these things
that are permanent,
these things that are constant,
and we've gotta
stand up for 'em.
So conservatives gotta
stand up and say,
"No, you know what,
"you don't get to be a woman
by just wanting to be a woman."
There is such a thing
as biological womanhood,
and it's awesome and
should be protected,
and girls playing sports
should be protected.
And men, on your
side of the aisle,
your side of the equation,
we need you to be
good, strong men,
and we need you to stand up
and be providers
and be responsible.
So we gotta do both.
And I think the left is really
attacking both men and women.
You can see it
and you can see it
in the huge number of kids now
who are totally confused
about their gender
and say that they
wanna transition,
they don't even know
what that means.
And it's being promoted
by leftist ideology
and the alliance with big tech.
- Yeah, one of Jordan
Peterson's lines on this is,
"Even if you were to take
the kid who is the 0.0001%
"that has gender dysmorphia,
"it doesn't mean after all
the hormones and surgeries
"that they're gonna be happier."
They most likely
won't be actually.
And that's in the case of
when it genuinely is real,
which obviously there's a social
contagion element to this.
- Yeah, totally,
and if you look at those
numbers, it's really striking.
If you look at the breakdown
in gender dysphoria
and those cases
clinically diagnosed
from, say, 10 years ago,
15 years ago, versus today,
it is impossible
to argue, I think,
that this isn't a
social contagion.
You look at it those years ago
and the huge explosion, huge
win, right around the time
the smartphone and social
media really take off
and that every teenager
in America has one,
boom, right then,
we see huge numbers.
The gender dysphoria issue
is concentrated largely
in young girls, in
teenage and preteen girls.
And we've seen just off
the charts numbers there,
and for the left
to say stuff like,
"Oh, we have to be for this.
"We've gotta promote gender
transition, gender surgery,
"hormone treatment."
I mean, I think this is crazy
when parents don't know,
if the parents
haven't consented,
looking at what is
really driving this,
the social contagion,
again, the left is so
out of touch with reality
and is so contrary
to what parents want.
- Are you guys in
Missouri doing anything
like what we've
done here in Florida
with the Parental Rights
in Education bill,
are they allowed to
do this in schools
without you knowing
as the parent?
- The Missouri legislature,
I think, has done
some really good work
both on parental rights
when it comes to schools
and then also just on this
gender treatment issue,
saying that, "Listen, parents,
"you can't push this gender
trans ideology on kids
"behind parents' back.
"You can't do this
without parental consent.
"without getting the
minor's full consent."
So just in those last
legislative session,
I think our legislators
have done some really
important stuff.
And it's gonna take, you
mentioned the states,
it's gonna take the
states stepping up here
and creating walls around
the family and saying,
"We're gonna protect parents
and we're gonna protect kids
"and we're gonna
empower parents."
Because if we don't do
that at the state level,
the bureaucrats will
just run roughshod
over families, over kids,
and they will push
their ideology
until they get what they want.
- Yeah, it's funny, I
can't really get Democrats
to come on this show anymore,
and I'm not noted as
the hardest interviewer,
and I would treat
them with respect,
but they simply
don't wanna do it.
But when you talk,
or I'm guessing
they don't talk to you
that often probably either,
but if you're in the Senate,
you're wandering
around the building,
the offices over there,
and you happen to see somebody,
Chuck Schumer, somebody,
I'm not talking one of
the real, real radicals,
someone that 20 years ago
might have been thought
of as somewhat sane,
did they buy this?
Didn't they all just
vote against a bill
that was gonna protect
girls in sports,
every single Democrat?
- Yeah, they did, over
on the House side.
And I'm sure they vote
against it in the Senate.
I don't know what
their real beliefs are.
I won't pretend
to speak for them,
but I just think that the
radical left, the Marxist left
has so captured the Democrat
party that they live in fear.
That's why they won't
say the word 'woman,'
they say people with
birthing capacity,
(David laughing)
when I say they,
I mean senators,
democrat senators won't
say woman anymore.
I mean, it is insane, insane.
And I think it is fear
of the radical left
who are so powerful
now in their party.
- Yeah, where do you think
education comes into this
in terms of what a man
should do with his life?
We sort of have this idea
that everybody had to go
to the four-year school.
We now know that
they were basically
brainwashing everybody,
but that there were
a lot of other jobs
and things that you can do in
your life that are valuable
without following that path.
- Oh yeah, I believe
that a hundred percent.
Listen, 70 plus
percent of American men
do not have a four-year
college degree.
They shouldn't have to get one
in order to get a good-paying
job in this country
and be able to
provide for a family.
That's my bottom line,
so I'm not for this,
shove kids and shove
young men in particular
towards four-year degrees,
make them take on
tremendous amounts of debt,
allow them to be brainwashed
by the university establishment
who are some of the
worst actors in America.
You talk about what they've
done to this country
while taking our money, by
the way, I mean, just taking,
gobbling up taxpayer money
and yet indoctrinating our kids.
So no, I'm not for forcing
people to go down that route.
I think that men ought to
be able to learn to trade,
they wanna do that,
get an associate's
degree, not go to college,
and they ought to be able
to get a good-paying job.
And I just come back to the
fact that our policy makers
have sent almost 4 million
blue-collar jobs to China
in the last 20 years.
Those jobs are jobs that used
to be able to support a family
overwhelmingly held by men.
We need good blue-collar
work in this country,
and if we don't get it, we're
not gonna have a country.
- So what would that
work look like now?
So let's say it's January
7th or January 12th, 2025.
Let's pretend we've got
a Republican president,
it worked out, you either got
Trump or DeSantis, let's say,
what's the policy that's gonna
actually bring jobs back,
these types of jobs?
- What I would do is I
put tariffs on China.
I put a 25% tariff
across the board
on all Chinese products
right now, I do it right now.
We have a massive
trade deficit with them
that is really, in my view,
the most important
deficit that we have,
and nobody wants
to talk about it.
It's so important because
it represents money
we are giving to them.
We are paying them
to take our jobs
and build their military on
the backs of our middle class.
Literally, that's
what's happened
for the last 20 plus years.
So I'd slap across the
board tariffs on China,
get that trade
deficit down to zero,
make it clear that we're
not going to allow them
to use their slave labor
in order to take away the wages
of our free laborers
here in this country.
So that would absolutely
begin the process
of bringing back our critical
supply chains to this country.
I think we can do
more required that,
listen, for our
critical supply chains,
a certain percentage
have to be made
in the United States of America.
It's a 'Make in America,
buy America' program.
And I'm not at all
bashful about this.
I think we shouldn't apologize
for saying that we want
stuff made in this country
and we're gonna
stop trade cheaters
and we're gonna stop
our adversaries from
taking our jobs.
I don't know why Republicans
are bashful about this,
and I don't think we should be.
- Well, let's just pray
the current administration
can't bang it up too much worse
for the next year and a half.
All right, I got two more,
now I'll give you the hard two.
- Okay.
- So now your sons,
they say to you,
"Dad, we wanna watch
whatever's on Disney,
"we wanna watch Mandalorian
or blah, blah, blah."
You don't wanna fund
Disney Plus, I'm guessing.
What's the answer as
a father on that one?
- Well, our answer so far,
and again, my boys are 10 and 8
and I recognize families
do this different ways,
but our answer is that our
kids watch very, very little TV
and they don't do any
social media, zero.
They absolutely do
not have phones.
They don't even have iPads.
And we try to keep our kids
off of social media completely
and frankly off of devices
as much as we possibly can.
And my wife deserves
the credit here.
She very carefully curates
what the kids watch.
She will watch the show before
they watch it, she's amazing.
That's what we do,
that's obviously hard.
And this is why I say it,
it's hard to be a
parent right now.
I mean, I'm a very
imperfect parent,
don't get me wrong,
I'm very imperfect.
But it is hard, hard when
you've got the whole culture
and these huge
corporations against you.
But yeah, I just think
we're in an age when,
it used to be right, when
I was a kid, you think,
"Oh, Disney, wholesome,
anything Disney, go for it."
That's not the case anymore.
- Yeah, I think there's
gonna be a lot of parents
busting out their VHS tapes
from Disney movies of 1985
just because they don't wanna
pay for Disney Plus anymore.
Let me ask you one other,
purely on the political front.
Obviously this 2025
thing is heating up it,
it's looking like a Trump
or DeSantis situation.
Can you just lay out,
I know you're not gonna
just drop a name for me,
but can you kind of lay out
what you see the
landscape looking like
that may lend itself to
either one of those guys?
- Well, I'll be honest with you,
I think Donald Trump's
gonna be the nominee.
I mean, I really do.
I think he will be
the nominee in 2024,
and I think it'll be
a Trump-Biden rematch.
I mean, I guess it'll be Biden.
I mean, to me, that's
the real shocker.
It's amazing to me the idea
that the Democrats would
renominate a man who clearly,
he's, number one, been
a terrible president,
the worst president
of my lifetime
and clearly is
not up to the job.
I mean, everybody knows this,
but looks to me like it's
gonna be a Trump-Biden rematch.
And I mean,
I'm sure as heck know
where I'm gonna be on that,
but I really do think Donald
Trump will be the nominee.
- Senator, I thank
you for your time.
- Thank you.
- The link for the book is
right down below, appreciate it.
- Thanks so much.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
(gentle music)
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.